jusqu'au 15 décembre au soir la
communauté juive est célèbre un look à
sa plus importante fête bonsoir au
rabbin mendel designboom bonsoir merci
d'être venu sur ce plateau alors que
dans une heure à peu près vous aller
allumer en public elle les bougies qui
symbolise ce rendez vous ce sera à
montigny le bretonneux elle sur la place
estienne françois choiseul chaque année
cet allumage publique est organisée à
nous-mêmes plusieurs à travers toute la
france c'est important d'avoir justement
cette ouverture à tous tout à fait c'est
une grande symbolique déjà du fait en
soi de cette fête de crâne ou kaki et la
fête des lumières
qui est en fait qui qui commémore une
histoire qu'il se passe quand même il y
a un peu près de 1100 et quelques années
on y sent 62 avant jésus-christ donc ou
antiochus tous voulaient hellénisé
antiochus 4 voulait hellénisé le monde
en fait mettre sa religion la rendre un
peu plus
l'obligeront va dire à ce que tout le
monde puisse plus l'accomplir puis cela
que tout le monde fasse la même chose et
il ya eu certes il ya eu donc cette
guerre puis cette victoire qui a fait en
sorte que chacun puisse faire ce qu'il
veut comme il le veut pas donc en fait
c'est une symbolique de d'ouverture de
montrer que chacun peut pratiquer chacun
peut penser chacun peut faire ce qu'il
veut et allumer des lumières allumé des
bougies à l'extérieur c'est juste
ajouter de la lumière à ce sera si vous
nous suivez en direct dans à peu près
une heure aux alentours de 20 heures à
saint quentin en yvelines on va tous tu
te partir justement dans les rues de
saint quentin en yvelines avant de
discuter plus longtemps avec vous en
tout cas vous l'avez dit c'est la fête
des lumières mais cette fête des
lumières est elle connue du grand public
c'est la question que nous lui avons
posé ces lions illuminé la fête de la
lumière
non non non je connais la fête de la
musique mais pas de la lumière non non
ça ne dit rien du tout a lyon c'est ça
sa fête des lumières à lyon celle de
lyon non pas du tout je ne connais pas
du tout non ça se passe ou à celle de la
lumière je connais une fête de lumière
méchas lyon c'est la sainte lucie c'est
en suède ou en norvège c'est ça on va
aller chercher les uns et les
renseignements sur internet histoire de
voir ce que c'est et puis je renseigne
aussi c'est ici il ya la fête de la
lumière des juifs notamment ce que ça
représente je n'en sais rien voilà bon
alors tout même on a trouvé une
saint-quentinoise qui savait c'est pas à
lyon la fête des lumières en
l'occurrence votre réaction sur le micro
trottoir ça prouve qu'il faut justement
l'importance de s'ouvrir pour partager
expliquer exactement
c'est partager expliqué en fait le but
informer sa voix il s'agit d'une fête
une fête de lumière rajouter de la
lumière donc ça concerne tout à chacun
je voulais c'est expliquer justement la
symbolique chaque année vous venez sur
le plateau vous m'expliquer c'est
toujours bon de faire une petite piqûre
de rappel or c'est quelle est la
symbolique de cette fête des lumières de
la lumière alors comme je le disais on
commémore une guerre qu'il y a eu il y a
à peu près 2000 100 ans donc on est
comme je l'avais dit 162 avant j'ai
écrit c'est ou en tout jusqu'à 36
épiphane a voulu
hellénisé le montre donc a voulu
l'elysée le monde donc réellement exigé
qu'il y ait qu'une seule religion c'est
là haut est entre à jérusalem c'est à
cette époque là il a fait le temple de
jérusalem ou introduit j.chirac 1 dans
toutes les maisons qu'il y ait qu'une
seule religion ce qui a formé bien sûr
une révolte plus une guerre donc à une
victoire militaire certes c'est pas
celle qu'on fait tellement c'est surtout
une fête de la lumière puisque après son
ombre les juifs donc les macchabées sont
entrés dans le temple dans le temple il
y avait coutume d'allumer un candélabre
tous les jours
cette fois ci donc qu'il cherchait de
l'huile ça lui met de l'huile d'olive
chercher de l'ul pour allumer ce
chandelier et ils n'ont pas trouvé
puisque toutes été saccagés ils
ont trouvé qu'une seule fils de will
keane fioles qui normalement pouvait une
journée puisque le ce chandelier du
temple brûlé toute la journée il ya eu
un miracle il a brûlé huit jours alors
que normalement à cette époque il
fallait huit jours pour fabriquer une
nouvelle huile donc chaque soir vous
allez mais une bougie ce soir vous en a
livré une supplémentaire ce jusqu'au 15
décembre jusqu'au 13 décembre au soir on
parle de la l'image de la menora mais
aussi de la nokia que la différence
alors ces deux mots différents fait
menora c'est un chandelier ghannouchi a
c'est le chandelier de crâne août a donc
effectivement comme ça les choses sont
plus claires cette année cette cérémonie
que vous organisez sera forcément un
petit peu plus particulière en raison de
l'actualité aussi il y aura la présence
est de samuel sender le président de la
communauté israélite de versailles qui
le 19 mars perdait son fils ses deux
petits-enfants également à devant le
collège ozar hatorah à toulouse avec la
tuerie perpétrée par mohamed merah cette
présence de samuel sandler ce sera
peut-être difficile aussi pour lui
d'être présent parce que récemment dans
les nouvelles de versailles il accordait
une interview il disait qu'il
s'interdisait de sourire et de faire la
fête aussi
tout à fait surtout que si je peux me
permettre de le dire mais la dernière
fait qu'il a passé avec c'est son fils
et ses petits enfants étaient justement
cette fête de lumière cette fête de
hanouka donc il me disait que c'est les
derniers travaux manuels de ses petits
enfants c'était sur cette fête justement
donc et c'était quand je l'aï appelé
pour lui demander d'allumer le show de
les bougies de ce soir il a accepté avec
grand plaisir et pour lui si tu es aussi
une signification un certain moment il
ya de l'obscurité c'est peut-être
obscures mais il faut passer de l'avant
il faut rajouter de la lumière éclaire
et une petite lumière peut chasser
énormément d'obscurité on parle souvent
de cette tuerie en la ferme est rare
vient quotidiennement quasiment dans
l'actualité avec des déclarations
récemment de sa soeur un livre aussi
publiée par as par son frère comment
vous le vivez au sein de la communauté
puis vous aussi même personnellement
peut-être cette situation actuellement
sachant que l'anc est en plus et
toujours et toujours en cours c'est dur
c'est dur parce que les événements sont
des événements il double re
catastrophique et donc avoir ravivé un
petit peu la douleur
remuer le couteau dans la plaie comme on
peut le dire ça fait mal est-ce que vous
avez le sentiment aujourd'hui que depuis
cette affaire aussi la communauté juive
et et plus menacé ce que vous sentez
moins en sécurité aussi
pas forcément c'est à dire surtout ici à
montigny nous ils vont très bien donc il
n'ya pas il n'y a pas moins de sécurité
ne sont pas moins en sécurité qu'avant
maintenant évidemment nos précautions
sont prises vos précautions sont prises
effectivement et ce soir cet allumage
qui aura lieu à montigny le bretonneux
je vais vous laisser vous y rendre parce
que si vous nous suivez en direct et
vous pouvez y aller c'est du côté de
montigny le bretonneux ce sera dans à
peu près une heure merci à vous d'être
venu nous parler de cette fête leur
hanouka je vous rappelle que vous pouvez
vous y rendre on part pour versailles
versailles et cette exposition qui se
déroule en ce moment au château
consacrée aux collections d'objets d'art
antique un patrimoine bien méconnu
johanna soudry elodie moines on oublie
peut-être mais le château de versailles
est empreint de mythologie l'exposition
versailles identique nous rappelle que
le domaine jadis baigner dans
l'antiquité collectionne les références
aux dieux et déesses ou 14 ans en
installant la cour et le gouvernement à
versailles en 782 uac coeur d'acheminer
quantité d'oeuvres antiques à versailles
le même
17e siècle antiquités est perçue comme
un enjeu politique
des artistes du roi redouble d'efforts
pour que leurs créations rivalisent avec
les beauté antique les collections sont
riches et le prestige du souverain et le
connaît si à l'époque versailles est
considérée comme la nouvelle rome ce
titre est aujourd'hui moins présente
dans les esprits le drame de versailles
c'est qu'à la révolution en fait que le
patrimoine mobilier avec soi été vendus
soit est parti à paris ou fournir les
collections du musée du louvre le musée
du louvre et le château de versailles
ont donc travaillé conjointement pour
présenter aux visiteurs 200 oeuvres
entre sculptures peintures tapisseries
et objets d'art savait qu'à cette époque
là l'étape était très sourcilleux sur
leur patrimoine y est très difficile
d'exporter des antiquités de rome et le
14 mai en moins a réussi à maintenir 3
durant son règne et des pièces majeures
et sont présentes dans cette exposition
il s'agit de trois statues germanicus
cincy natus et le centaure albanie
p'tit louis xiv a pu rassembler des
antiques venus du monde entier comme le
moyen-orient avec l'apollon de smyrne il
s'est aussi vu offrir des sculptures à
l'image de la vénus tard dans
l'exposition au premier étage on peut
voir deux tableaux réalisés sur des
thèmes antiques à la demande en 2014 ont
collectionnées par une huile
ainsi que des éléments de décor du
mobilier des boiseries des vases
l'exposition compris dans le billet
d'entrée du château est accessible
jusqu'au 17 mars 2013